[Musique]
bienvenue dans cet entretien commun rfi
france24 bonjour antoine grenier
journaliste au service des sports de rfi
bonjour benoît bonjour à tous on met le
plaisir de recevoir ici à paris un homme
à qui tout sourit depuis maintenant six
mois champion d'afrique pour la première
fois est le sénégal c'était en début
d'année au cas où une qualifiée pour le
mondial au qatar est cet automne bonjour
aly cissé à sélectionneur des lions de
la teranga bonjour à tous très heureux
d'être avec vous merci à leur coach vous
êtes de passage en france mais on a du
mal à imaginer que c'est vraiment que
pour les vacances ou en profiter pour
venir voir quelques joueurs et pour
travailler un petit peu c'est un petit
peu les deux savaient se fait depuis
pratiquement deux ans vide mais je suis
revenu en france du fait de cette
pandémie de
decaux vide effectivement la première
chez oc d'abord venir voir ma mère ça
faisait deux ans que j'étais pas venu le
voir le football c'est très bien et je
crois que la famille aussi a besoin de
demain effectivement on en profite aussi
pour entrer en contact avec avec avec
certains joueurs mais pour l'instant
vraiment cette visite là c'est surtout
une visite familiale alors cinq mois
après le sacre du sénégal votre sénégal
est ce que vous avez eu le temps de
digérer justement toutes ces émotions
oui tout à fait on essaie de de digérer
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des échéances
très importantes qu'une eau qui nous
attend et qui arrive très très très vite
ce qui a été bien c'est que après ce
sacre lab rapidement on a eu deux
matches très décisifs qui ont été les
éliminatoires de la coupe d'europe coupe
du monde face à la même équipe qui
l'egypte on a on a pu faire le travail
et se et se qualifier et puis par la
suite au mois de juin dernier quand vous
le voyez il y avait des éliminatoires
aussi delà de la coupe d'afrique en 2001
2002 donc en réalité c'est depuis ce
sacre là on n'a jamais arrêté et ce qui
est bien c'est qu'on a quand même bien
négocier ces périodes là après calmes
après victoire avec tous et free qui
avait autour de cette équipe nationale
nous sommes très satisfaits et nous
préparons vraiment cette coupe du monde
avec
avec beaucoup de sérénité cette double
confrontation contre l'egypte que vous
évoquiez en éliminatoires enfin barrages
de la coupe du monde ça vous a permis
justement de digérer encore plus vite le
titre de champion d'afrique il est
difficile de digérer un titre qu'on
attendait plus pratiquement 60 ans mais
effectivement le football comme vous le
savez c'est quelque chose de
dense table dont qu il était important
et je le disais souvent à mon staff que
l'après sacre les trois matches les
quatre matches qui vont qui vont
s'enchaîner y sera très très important
de remobiliser notre kim est arrivé à
faire les bons résultats je crois qu'on
a pu le on a pu le faire et ça c'est
très bien pour la suite non vous
regarder évidemment et vous en avait
déjà parlé à l'est ou vers le qatar vers
cette coupe du monde sera l'objectif de
la fin de l'année de l'automne avec
quelles ambitions réelles et raisonnable
pour les lions de la teranga champions
d'afrique mais qui n'avait pas passé la
phase de groupes au mondial en 2018
froid que quatre ans sont sur son passé
on a eu le temps de magasiner encore
plus d'expérience collective si je peux
je peux je peux parler comme ça
aujourd'hui nous y allons nous y allons
avec beaucoup d'ambition mais tout en
restant aussi réaliste ne pas oublier
aussi que la dernière coupe du monde on
a été éliminés ou non parce qu'on avait
pris un carton deux de plus mais c'était
pas sur le terrain derrière c'était une
première pour une équipe éliminée au
carton et ça je pense que c'est
important vous les journalistes que
voulez vous le remarquez vous le dit et
maintenant à côté de ça c'est vrai qu'on
a une équipe compétitive je le disais
avant d'être champion d'afrique on était
attendus aujourd'hui on sera encore plus
attendu mais quand je le dis nous avons
des ambitions mais ces ambitions là
doivent est aussi réaliste et hervé
atteignable mais ce serait quoi une
coupe du monde réussie
c'est d'aller le plus loin possible tout
simplement d'abord sortir de cette poule
là et puis à partir de ce que à partir
des huitièmes de finale on sait que tout
et tout et tout est possible c'est vous
gagnez vous continuez vous perdez vous
rentrez à la maison je crois que c'est
genre de match là on a l'habitude de les
jouer on a le vécu on a l'expérience
pour pour ça donc en réalité au niveau
romand avec avec beaucoup d'humilité on
y va avec beaucoup d'ambition et on y va
aussi avec eux
avec beaucoup de confiance il ya deux
trois nations africaines qui ont atteint
les quarts de finale d'une coupe du
monde dont le sénégal en 2002 votre
sénégal à l'époque si vous étiez joueur
à entraîneur mes joueurs comment faire
pour que ça soit plus à un exploit pour
une nation africaine d'arriver en quarts
de finale mais que ça devienne la
normalité il faut pas être super fort en
mathématiques pour comprendre que plus
on est nombreux ma plus on a des chances
d'arriver au bout aujourd'hui quand vous
prenez les éliminatoires de la
dea éliminateur de la coupe du monde
dans la zone afrique vous avez vu les
difficultés aujourd'hui vous êtes dans
un continent qui est traité de la même
façon que les autres continents alors
que c'est un continent qui est différent
c'est un continent qui est spécifique
aujourd'hui vous prenez le continent
africain vous avez au moins quinze cdc
équipe capable de se qualifier à cette
coupe du monde il a alors que nous ne
sommes que cinq donc ça veut dire que
les modes de qualifications aujourd'hui
son son sens à voir mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la caf est en train de
travailler dessus pour que dans les
prochaines échéances dans les prochains
éliminatoires qu'on puisse avoir une
dizaine d'équipés ou une quinzaine
d'équipés africaines et là à partir de
là oui on pourra dire que
les chances sont un petit peu pareil et
qu'il ya une équipe africaine qui est
capable d'aller le plus loin possible et
y aurait peut-être en rendez vous
messieurs en quarts de finale avec
l'équipe de france si jamais tout le
monde se qualifie coupe du monde en tout
cas très particulière décalé à l'automne
avec une préparation tronquée pour
l'ensemble des sélections des joueurs à
leur pic de forme et est finalement une
compétition qui serait encore plus belle
une coupe du monde au mois de novembre
nous à laquelle on se plaignait qu'on
n'avait pas le temps de préparation
parce qu'on avait quinze jours là
effectivement qu'on vous le voyez bien
écouté de cette coupe du monde là on
aura seulement une semaine donc d'où
l'importance aujourd'hui où tout mon
inquiétude aussi de 2,2 de voir nos
joueurs leur destination les transferts
parce qu'il est important si vous voulez
entre juin j'ai août jusqu'à septembre
et peut-être même jusqu'en novembre que
nos joueurs et la compétitivité
actuellement vous avez bien vu comment
ça se passe dans le club d'autres sont
en instance d de partance d'autres ils
ne savent pas exactement comment comment
gérer cette situation là et tout ça
c'est vrai que c'est des casse tête un
petit peu pour nous les sélectionneurs
mais si nous arrivons serait arrivé
vraiment que nos joueurs soient
compétitifs dans ce laps de temps là
entre juillet et novembre on aura notre
mot à dire sur cette coupe du monde
avant d'en venir aucun particulier vos
joueurs vous le disiez la préparation de
cette coupe du monde elle va être très
très très resserrée pour ne pas dire
encore plus comment faire pour vous dont
le mois de septembre va être consacrée
aux éliminatoires de la can est ce que
c'est pas une difficulté supplémentaire
qu'on vous mais là j'ai fait un appel et
cet appel là je crois que c'est au nom
de tous les entraîneurs aujourd'hui
africains qui sont qualifiés à la coupe
du monde de savoir que on a besoin quand
même un minimum de préparation
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
représenter dignement pas seulement le
sénégal mais toute l'afrique aujourd'hui
parce que c'est l'afrique qui va en
compétition
c'est vrai que ce mois de septembre là
devraient nous permettent en réalité
mais c'est pas encore décidée par notre
part notre confédération nous espérons
qu'ils prendront la décision de pouvoir
tout simplement décalé ces éliminatoires
de la can et en lieu il y mettre
justement des matches amicaux que les
équipes les cinq représentants du
continent africain puisse vraiment se
préparer nous croisons les doigts
émergents nous avons espoir alors on a
parlé aussi beaucoup ces dernières
semaines du transfert de sadio manille
qui s'est conclue à ces vitesses que ça
ça a été un soulagement pour vous
justement que cette affaire elle traîne
pas dans le temps tout à fait parce que
aujourd'hui en tant que sélectionneur
c'est ça notre notre notre hantise
de voir nos joueurs ne pas connaître
rapidement leur destination est
aujourd'hui le fait que sa yo man et
très vite à quitter liverpool son
contrat a été réglée sur pense que pour
le garçon
dans sa tête c'est mieux il pourra
vraiment bien préparé c'est 4 5 mois qui
vont manquer vont arriver et réalité
c'est ce que je voudrais de l'ensemble
de mon rendement de mon équipe que ces
problèmes de contrôle à que c'est être
réglé d'ici septembre pourquoi justement
qu'on puisse penser carrément cette
préparation de la coupe du monde
aujourd'hui c'est un duo eto'o est un
grand joueur et comme tout entraîneur
vous mettez vos stratégies vous mettez
vos plans de jeu par rapport à vos à
vomir joueurs sayo fait partie de l'aude
le dos de nos meilleurs joueurs et koné
ses responsabilités mais il lisse et
cueilli il n'y a pas que lui et autour
de lui a aussi d'autres cadres qui
travaillent et qui l'appuie et nous
aussi dans le staff nous sommes en train
de l'appuyer et n'a jamais été seul et
il ne sera pas seul maintenant c'est
vrai que les leaders bas les leaders
c'est forcément ils doivent prendre
aussi beaucoup plus de responsabilités
et ils ont un peu plus de pression que
les autres joueurs mais j'ai envie de
dire qu' il le gère bien depuis
pratiquement dix ans qu'il est en
sélection et continuera le à le gérer
pour moi c'est alors le sort la
destination sadio man et sa série
boucler le transfert est bouclée mais il
ya d'autres joueurs il ya des
incertitudes qui sont en instance de
départ comment vous êtes vous en tant
que sélectionneur est ce que vous êtes
plutôt du genre à passer un coup de fil
à votre joueur en le conseillant vous
attendez que plutôt le joueur vous
appelle en vous demandant conseil à ma
venue ici aussi en français c'est sympa
ça c'est c'est essayer justement de
parler à ces garçons là qui sont en
instance de départ ou bien qui sont en
difficulté dans leur club on arrive à a
parlé ils sont plutôt optimistes ils
savent ce qu'ils veulent maintenant
c'est vrai que le temps est notre ennemi
il va falloir rapidement rapidement
trouver un point de chute dans leur club
soit par un transfert soit par ailleurs
par un prêt pour que justement qu'ils
puissent y être compétitif dès le mois
de septembre pour pouvoir donner bien
préparé cette peau se coupent de monclar
parmi ces joueurs qui vont être beaucoup
mis en concurrence au sein de leurs
clubs il ya abdou diallo et idrissa
gueye
visiblement le paris saint-germain
recrute notamment au milieu de terrain
vous conseilleriez ghana de partir du
paris saint-germain de trouver un autre
point de chute je comprends pas je pense
que ghana a déjà fait ses preuves au
paris saint germain je pense qu'il n'a
pas été plus mauvais que quand un autre
l'année dernière et même dans deux cas
il ya deux ans maintenant c'est les
choix de des propriétaires du club c'est
les choix aujourd'hui du paris saint
germain mais je n'ai aucun doute que
ghana va trouver un club digne de ce nom
là un club où il va continuer à
performer un club où il va continuer à
montrer ses véritables qualités
maintenant comme je dis ce qui est
important pour nous dans le jeu
inventant le toit de jeu est important
bien sûr le temps de jeu important
maintenant tout sélectionneur envie que
ces joueurs jouent mais la réalité est
autre maintenant à côté de ça ce sont
des joueurs professionnels
aujourd'hui il s'entraîne normalement
ils sont dans un groupe de performance
et ce sont les choix d'un entraîneur en
entraîneurs qui décident tout simplement
par rapport à son choix de jeu de ne pas
faire jouer un joueur mais c'est pas
parce que le jour est inapte ou bien
c'est parce que le joueur il est blessé
non ils sont compétitifs et c'est toutes
ces difficultés là quand on est
sélectionneur en réalité c'est un manque
de temps de jeu c'est dû à quoi est ce
que c'est les blessures puisque c'est
les choix des entraîneurs est ce
qu'aujourd'hui je peux me permet de dire
qu'un jour qui ne jouent pas dans son
club n'est pas sélectionnable non je ne
le ferai pas non parce que j'ai été
footballeur professionnel et je sais que
par moment ce sont des choix tout
simplement d'un entraîneur par rapport
au schéma tactique ou par rapport tout
simplement à des situations dans le club
qui sont qui sont plutôt là donc je les
encourage à continuer à travailler et
puis on fera le point ici des séquelles
comment alors dans la perspective du
mondial vous travaillez comment l'idée
c'est de poursuivre avec ce groupe qui a
été jusqu'au bout à la can ou alors
d'apporter un petit peu de sang neuf
justement il ya donc deux choses qui
doivent progresser dans cette dans cette
équipe là et partout on peut trouver les
joueurs qui sont capables si vous voulez
aujourd'hui de nous apporter en plus
c'est notre devoir d'aller les
rencontrer parler avec eux avec eux
maintenant il s'agit pas de faire une
révolution parce qu'en réalité il ya un
groupe quand même qu'à montrer ses cafés
ses preuves et en groupe aujourd'hui qui
est en train de performer depuis
pratiquement quelques années ensemble
qu'ils ont l'habitude d'être ensemble
mais comme je le dis aussi bas il est
important de renforcer l'équipe aussi
dans d'autres domaines et nous sommes en
train d'y travailler merci c'est la fin
de cet entretien merci aliou cissé on a
compris que le sénégal l'objectif
c'était au moins les quarts de finale à
la coupe du monde on vous souhaite un
bel été un bel été studieux on imagine
avant avancé de coupe du monde et les
éliminatoires de la can en septembre
merci antoine grenier un bel homme abel
été studieux à vous aussi on va essayer
vous avez essayé jusqu'à jusqu'à cet
hiver voilà
[Musique]